i think you got further than me and jump
king as well oh yeah i've been i've been
grinding on that that jump king that is
painful absolutely okay have you played
jump king no i've been trying to get
like a bunch of people to let's just go
with me though because i really want to
play it it's like you don't want to go
on a jump kick
before i agree to this i could be
agreeing to like a [ __ ] suicide pact
foreign are we jumping off a cliff
is that what jump king is this is code
word we're doing the jump king
let's not explain what jump kill all
right honestly like the best way to
experience it in my opinion just going
blind because that's that's what
happened to me what's the game with the
pickaxe and the no no no no we're
getting over it yeah imagine over it
imagine getting over it with jumping
yeah that's literally it yeah have you
played getting over it no better body's
getting over you know what the guy it's
the naked guy in the pot you have to
like use the pickaxe to get to the top
of the mouth oh yeah i know that like
imagine that but jumping imagine that
but jumping yeah okay yeah and you're a
kid okay
and you can just fold it's got really
good pixel art as well okay the art is
amazing yeah but it is it's a journal
jump it's basically doodle jump is
doodle jump
with getting over it yeah exactly okay
it is rough it is very difficult but the
way that i've gotten around it is i've
started jumping into voice chat uh with
my with a whole live post
okay all right
i just want to know if you could
accept new applicants
but i've been sitting in voice chat just
waiting i've just been waiting for um
other members to jump in and have a
little chat with me and um the time flew
by i got into chat and two of the other
members iris and bay just jumped into
voice chat and we just talked about
anime the whole time that i was
suffering trying to climb this building
and eight hours just flew by it was
amazing oh yeah well yeah i mean i guess
without it it's like you're basically in
solitary confinement right yeah exactly
sounds horrible
that's why i want to race it right so i
can distract myself by talking [ __ ] to
other people so what is the point of
jump king is there like an enemy at the
top to jump to the top save the princess
okay okay so hot lady yeah
smoking hot babies
thank you for explaining to me what
jumping is like i have a general idea
now
i would like to try streaming
don't get my hopes up
see all of you race in jump king yeah we
should you can be the mc all right
gotcha i'll narrate the whole thing
so is it like get over it where it's
easy to reach or where it's like really
hard to reach the end in one place yeah
and it's really easy to just like fall
down and fall to the bottom yeah you
could have been playing for like five
hours and you've made it so many levels
up and then just one wrong fall leads to
a chain of more wrong falls that put you
down at the very first stage and then
you get tilted and then you start just
throwing you can't remember how to jump
in the certain places that you were
jumping before you just run into a blind
rage after all love it can't wait can't
wait it's great it's really going to
test
oh my god yeah what's like your favorite
type of content to make then is it
playing games or is it like
interacting with the chat ah let's see
you know interestingly enough i felt
like my my interaction skills with chat
were kind of non-existent in the
beginning um to be completely honest is
because i was big old baby um especially
towards the beginning big old baby big
baby
terrifying knowing that i'm bad at video
games i was really kind of scared to
check the chat because i didn't want to
lose you know energy and momentum by
seeing someone say hey you suck because
while i while i'm aware i'm not very
good at video games it's like seeing
everyone telling you how to do a certain
thing
even if i can hold back a reaction or a
snarky remark it does bring down the
energy a bit and i want to stay high
energy you know so it's something i had
to learn to do to like really kind of
put up a wall between you know
people leaving you know funny comments
or like just general feedback and people
screaming at you in all caps uh that you
should be using a pickaxe to
to break stones instead of a shovel
which is i will say that is a good piece
of advice and i appreciate it
i'm more likely to listen to it if it's
phrased not in all caps though
that's a general just a good idea for
for chet i would say in general i don't
really actually care too much about back
seating it's like
it's when it gets to be everyone and
super aggressive that my energy begins
to fall so i had to kind of learn to
like hey callie get over it just you
know try and try and like
like turn your vision into a way that it
can just pick out
comments and chat that like that aren't
entirely aggressive and you keep the
stream going and so i do like
interacting with chat these days uh chad
can be funny they have some they have
some jokes
yeah guys have jokes out there i will
say um and they really do kind of
brighten up my day so it's been worth it
um in the end but i'd say my favorite
kinds of streams to do
probably variety streams though they do
take the most preparation
recently i've been trying to do eikaiwa
streams so like english uh learning by
speaking simple and slow english for
anyone really not only japanese viewers
but people around the world who maybe
have english as a second language um
that takes a lot of preparation when you
said english learning i was like you
learning english
i think you've already got that down
guys i'm going to do an english learning
stream today
stream next week we're going to perform
the poker rap
to be fair i should you know you should
do a dueling english speed run see how
see how good you are in english
seriously
i feel like i would be way worse than i
i think i have any likes to be in
english in duolingo
i feel like i don't know that's that's
an interesting stream actually so you're
seeing if you are as fluent in english
as you're like something like duolingo
thinks you are yeah
what's what's the main language then
that you have the application set on if
you're learning english does it have to
be can it be english again
yeah i guess that's a good question
i don't think duolingo has ever thought
about that before so
you know uh this is going to sound so
bad so when you know i'm learning
japanese right yeah and they're like oh
yeah it's like a it's it's like a
pronoun and i was like yeah
for the first time i hear i was like
what is that again
i was like what's the foreign
i know but like you know you hear
actually like i haven't heard that been
like you know when you're different
types of verbs and nouns you're like
wait hold on let me refresh my memory of
what that is again hold up it's been
like five years i remember what a
pronoun is
because they obviously think when when
the japanese teacher is teaching me
japanese they're like oh you know this
stuff it's english it's fluent you speak
it right and it's like yeah yeah i
remember that stuff i remember
absolutely i don't think that works when
it comes to learning languages though to
me at least when i hear something as a
pronoun i don't think i remember well as
as we've just established we don't know
what the [ __ ] pronoun is isn't in is
in our own language how the [ __ ] are we
going to learn that in another language
it's so embarrassing when i'm there in
front of the teacher who is japanese and
she's like oh it's just like this thing
and i'm like yeah
i know what that is yeah exactly i'm
like totally i know what that is
okay
i know what an adjective is
[Music]
like a noun and verbs are the ones that
you should know and then anything else
i'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah
proverb
i know how to use i don't know what that
is i mean i know i know that it exists
but if you i don't exist
i should know this is my language tell
me how to use a semicolon
[Laughter]
i don't know if you just heard like the
groan across the office
i will use a cola semicolon i don't
think i'm remotely correct but i will
throw one in there just for good measure
i kind of use it like using a comma and
a full stop at the same time
kind of sentence you actually know the
way that i think i learned how to use
semicolon yeah the lonely island song
semicolon yeah
i remember that yeah
i was like oh that actually that's the
first time i've seen the explanation of
semicolon yeah i'm like that makes sense
now that makes sense yeah i don't know i
just feel like with the era of like
water corrects and [ __ ] like that we
just pay way less attention to it like
i've just started using apostrophes in
places where apostrophes don't need to
be used but like it just looks right and
i i know it's wrong sometimes well it's
like with uh languages like japanese
sometimes that some people some of the
younger generation don't know how to
write the kanji because they're typing
it all the time yeah
and that's like a thing yeah
is that true joey yes
absolutely i mean other countries and
characters as well that's like a big
problem yeah yeah because i like when i
was in school i you know i took like the
kanji proficiency test so obviously i
was like just used to writing it all
yeah but once i got that degree i was
like all right cool never have to write
this [ __ ] ever again and now when i look
at it or now when someone's like how do
you write this i just kind of stop and
i'm like
i should know this
but i can't write it yeah and there's so
many symbols like that yeah you've done
language learning streams as well
uh japanese as well isn't it how's that
been going i can't really do them as
much anymore because of like certain
permissions issues but um i'm thinking
of getting back into it with just uh you
know making a list of vocabulary
beforehand and running through flash
cards with with chat because i feel like
um
that can be entertaining in its own way
i think somehow it always becomes a fun
time even ideas that i think are going
to be kind of boring yeah it ends up
being fun